ben affleck reveals how he's spending  the holidays with his family should be a  lot of fun it's been a busy year for the  multi-talented star so it makes sense  he's taking some much deserved time off  I can tell you that we're going to do  skiing in Montana our family and matt  damon's family and my brother's family  should be a lot of fun ET spoke with ben  tuesday night in new york city at a  special screening of his new crime drama  live by night i'm lucky i worked with  tremendous cast this movie had a great  crew and i was very lucky this is heaven  we're in it now not only did ben act  write and direct the project he also  co-produced it alongside Leonardo  DiCaprio I know pretty well he's a very  good guy he's a friend of mine and a  really smart guy and somebody who  understands a lot about movies you don't  think I'm strong enough I don't know if  you're cruel enough powerful men don't  have to be cruel  [Music]  you